here's the news from the ap donald
trump's been impeached
after capital riot in historic second
charge
again they say president donald trump
was impeached by the u.s house for a
historic second time wednesday
charged with incitement of insurrection
over the deadly mob siege in the capital
in a swift and stunning collapse of his
final days in office
we get it several republicans actually
joined in there were 10 that's kind of
surprising but not too surprising
interestingly we heard that mitch
mcconnell would not be calling
a special session of the senate which
means the actual trial for donald trump
will have to
will happen after biden is already
present president
but you need to understand there is one
thing they are doing here
before i tell you what that one thing is
i'll note donald trump put out a big
statement today on video on youtube for
the white house saying
no violence and no law breaking and if
you look back at what donald trump said
in dc he said
peacefully protest peacefully march to
cheer on politicians
he didn't tell anybody to do anything
direct or to storm the capital or any of
that stuff
but that's not what's important the
democrats are levying a charge of
incitement of insurrection for
one reason if trump is convicted
for insurrection that is grounds to
prevent him from running in 2024.
that's what they're after and that's why
they are now trying to
impeach him even though i'm sorry i'm
sorry they did impeach him
that's why they're hoping to convict him
even after he
leaves office so i've heard from a lot
of people they've said it's too late
you'll never get a senate trial in time
what's the point there's many
republicans who are like why is only
eight days left
because they don't want him to be able
to have any political power
ever again and they want to do the same
thing to all these other republicans who
supported trump
in the constitutional process of
objecting to the vote so i don't know
what you guys think but uh
i think it's doomed to fail unless you
think they're republicans who are
actually gonna you know they need 67
votes
i mean uh i mean who knows mcconnell
seems to really hate trump right now
uh who knows where that will go uh the
question is you know is uh is trump like
trump like the uh the obi-wan kenobi of
getting impeached every time you do it
he gets stronger because he does have
this image of you know
the one guy against everyone else and
this seems to bolster that image
yeah yeah the if you strike me down i'll
become more possible more powerful than
you could possibly imagine
that's that's the bigger question beyond
all of this though so i rolled my eyes
when it's like here we go with
impeachment again and they really
dragged it out
it was like they announced we're going
to impeach trump on monday and then on
monday they were like oh here we go
but we're going to give mike pence 24
hours
48 hours we're gonna impeach him on
wednesday
and then they finally do it didn't they
need like nine months to decide
that the average citizen gets 600 but
when it comes to impeachment they could
just do it like that i mean
it you know this is a major thing but i
feel like it's losing its lackluster
it was such a major big deal with bill
clinton when he was impeached he still
obviously was
able to be president but now it's like
okay we get the kind of larger symbolic
gestures and i feel like there's a lot
of them
that essentially don't really amount to
a lot what
the gestures well the the larger kind of
uh saying you know trump's out
you know trying to just to push anything
trump out like we saw the golf course
we saw new york city also announced
today that they're getting that they're
getting rid of any contracts they had
with trump including uh his property in
the bronx including his ice skating rink
in central park so we're seeing just a
lot of people using this situation
to kind of stand on the grave of donald
trump saying look how good i am
by dumping trump and that's crazy
because trump's popular still
like the trump supporters still love the
man just because out of president he's
not president anymore doesn't mean
they're gonna sit by and just
let these people destroy everything
trump i think him getting banned
made people love him like he got all
this sympathy after he got banned off
twitter
because people were ready to start
hating on him and now all of a sudden
well you know what it is
i think the trump reply guys and these
journalists on the left are sweating
bullets
like you're gonna get laid off like jim
acosta's already gone
you guys saw that right no what happened
cnn announced that jim acosta is no
longer the white house you know
correspondent
well he served his purpose well
you can look it that way or you can just
look at it as jim acosta
was doing a job for cnn but without
trump
he's literally nothing the it's
he served his purpose i think sounds too
nice
it's that jim acosta doesn't have
anything going for him the only thing he
had was that he was the guy who was
willing to waste everyone's time
just blabbering at trump and not ask
actually asking questions
i'll be the first breitbart reporter
accused of being too nice to jim acosta
no but it is you served your purpose and
you can go and i'm like well well well
he was useless from the get-go until
trump came in yes no for real
that's better actually yeah yeah i mean
did anyone know jim acosta before trump
nope no i mean i i think i don't even
know what he was doing for cnn he was
the white house press corps for a while
i remember meeting him
um oddly enough at bilderberg but he
wasn't covering bilderberg he was just
staying at the bilderberg hotel before
the actual conference was happening
and that's where i actually met him and
um so so what you're saying he actually
got fired
uh if he was the white house
correspondent before
trump this was years and years ago um
and uh i gotta i gotta look up the dates
to to verify it but he was the white
house correspondent
yeah he was the white house uh
correspondent for a while they gave me
the boot you see
they're shutting down their airport
network yeah yeah cnn airport is gone
they're just because without
trump they're in panic yeah and you know
jeff zucker the president of cnn was
like you know it's the
it's the lack of air travel from you
know because of covid and the changing
way people are consuming media and i'm
like
yeah but what about cnn hotels like
hotels play cnn all the time
but i guess they were paying the airport
so that makes sense that they would
terminate that i wonder what the
airports are going to do oh no they're
just going to leave cnn on
i think that's actually a bet cnn
probably made i mean they have all these
tvs the airports airports aren't going
to turn them off
they don't have to play something wasn't
there rumors about zucker potentially
leaving cnn 2 recently
yeah yeah yeah yep okay the the whole
ecosystem the whole
economic system of the media was built
on donald trump for four years
that's why i've been saying before the
media secretly wants trump to win
but they can't say it or contribute to
it but deep down they're like what am i
gonna do
like there's an op-ed from one
journalist freaking out being like my
whole career was built on calling out
trump and now he's gone what do i do
and it was like some other journalist
talking them down like calm down calm
down
you'll figure it out you'll you'll
evolve from this i was surprised to see
the krasenstein brothers uh celebrating
uh in a short video
if if you don't know that there are two
guys who the only people the only reason
anyone knows their name is because they
were trump reply guys on twitter
they got their following through
responding to donald trump they were
celebrating him getting banned well you
know
that's how you that's how people know
who you are
but this whole thing about corporate
corporations banks cutting off trump
social media companies cutting off trump
it's kind of has a silver lining in a
way because it shows where power lies
in america and it's raised this issue
now i think to international concern
you've got foreign leaders
who are horrified to see i was i was
really uh um
uh what's what's the right word uh not
shocked i was impressed
you know to see bastions of human rights
and civil liberties
standing up just give gave me hope you
know like like uh china
and uganda calling out these these
horrific acts that were being carried
out in the united states
bravo well one thing that's really
interesting is that there is
international outrage about what's
happening in the united states with the
banning of the us president on social
media kind of transferring the power of
information into the small hands of a
few
select billionaires and it's a few
french ministers
angela merkel uh the mexican president
and and a lot of other people
are actually australian ministers as
well and there are reports the british
prime minister is now considering uh
regulations on tax censorship now this
is interesting yeah this is interesting
because
we don't hear about this at all like
there's no outcry there's celebration on
social media that were shown on
mainstream media which calls for more
heads to roll
uh but but we don't hear any of the
legitimate concerns that are are very
serious i mean we're living in a
situation where
essentially a few people have total
control they privatize
the internet and they could do whatever
they want with this vast
ever growing power that has so much
influence on our lives and it's
absolutely scary
people outside of the us are realizing
it and
no one's even hearing about it yeah so
american elites love the fact that these
tech companies can stamp down on their
political opponents
but no one in any other country really
likes the idea of that because they
don't want an american they don't want
an american company coming and picking
and choosing their elected leaders
chancellor of germany doesn't want that
the prime minister doesn't want that the
dictator of uganda doesn't want that he
just banned
twitter and facebook before his election
well they understand this kind of bigger
merger
of big tech and the biden administration
that's hiring all these tech executives
to be a part of its government
this merger is going to have vast power
not just
in the united states but specifically
the world whenever there's a protest
whenever there's a demonstration
whenever there's a world leader that
doesn't play along
that doesn't do whatever the elites want
him to do whatever the billionaire class
wants done if if they don't do it if
they don't jump when they say jump
they're gonna have all the power in the
world to shut someone down
everywhere because of their speech and
and we have to understand this is not
just twitter or facebook
these are monopoly powers of amazon and
google that
control the key infrastructures of our
information highways
so whether it's server space whether
it's internet cables
these people have so much power way
beyond
just social media algorithms so it's
interesting poland
they announced this bill i don't know if
you guys saw this yes where they're
gonna
you know reign in big tech i actually
have this uh the story from new york
post written by will chamberlain
he writes poland appropriately enough is
leading the way
their justice minister zigbanu zeobro
announced last month the polish
government would enact a law
constraining big tech from censoring
their citizens
polish users who are victims of
censorship can go to a new polish court
get an injunction forcing the company to
restore their account and their content
on penalty of a fine of as much as 1.8
million
euro we should do the same americans
should have the same right to speak on
large social media platforms
that they do in a public park we simply
need to change the law
to make that a reality you know what i
love the most about this here i am you
know
ten years ago uh fundraising and doing
you know engaging in activism
to regulate major corporations why oil
spills
big political lobbying violation of
civil liberties
and you know you have these big evil
companies
and here i am today doing the exact same
thing no weird yet now
conservatives have joined in and it's
really interesting to see the left has
abandoned me
where'd they go they no longer want to
regulate the companies that are seizing
the commons
i made an analogy to this on twitter
where i said i had an epiphany after
being told but my private company for
the
500 millionth time and i realized that
all the activism i did for the
environment was wrong
bp is a private company if they want if
they have if they build an
oil rig in the ocean and they're
permitted to do it and oil spills out of
it
well too bad why don't you start a
company to clean up that oil
and i know of course they all said
that's a different thing it's a
different problem that doesn't make
sense i said it certainly makes sense
bp cause damage to the commons the areas
that we all share
that must be protected so that people
can use them in that
destruction and damage we all got mad
and there are regulations to
prevent them from doing this what i see
with big tech and social media
is them shutting down legal political
speech
in the commons where we have our they've
taken over the town square
people aren't going out and going to
church to talk anymore they're not going
to community centers they're doing it on
twitter
and the big tech companies shut that
down and i believe they need to be
regulated
in some capacity and this sounds like a
good solution allow people to get an
injunction
well this latest news definitely made me
feel more polish and proud from my home
country
but we have to understand europe has
been taking a very different approach
than the united states when it comes to
big tech for
a long time when it comes to regulations
fines and penalties
social media has been kind of pushed
back there more than
i would say anywhere else in the world
but also specifically with poland and
other countries like hungary
i also recently saw an article saying
that the biden administration
is eyeing poland and hungary to get back
at it for some of the kind of
close relations that they had previously
with donald trump
and because of their implementation of
policies that don't go along
with of course the the kind of global
order that the people want to push the
global reset
immigration uh you know nationalism
those are key important issues that
poland and hungary hold
close to their heart that of course is
different than the rest of europe and
that's why we're seeing
uh the biden administration kind of set
its eyes on that specific region because
they're going to be implementing
policies that are going to affect it in
very negative ways and you especially
see this with hungary where you had the
state department actually funding
opposition media in hungary the reason
why they particularly dislike that
country
is because hungary is trying to get the
ngos out of the country
the ngos are of course arms of u.s
influence abroad they're all funded by
usaid or the state department didn't
they ban
soros they banned the soros ngos yes it
was quite a while ago
you know it's interesting i think you
were telling me something luke because
uh i grew up
in amsterdam chicago in a very polish
neighborhood
and of course there's always the
stereotype about polish people not being
smart
you mentioned that it was because the
soviet union executed the intelligentsia
of poland
yes well when russia came in they
they took a lot of the professionals
whether doctors whether professors
teachers and they executed a lot of them
or sent some of them to siberia
in order to gain cultural control of
larger institutions that they were
able to implement communism that the
polish people hated and they resisted
and and that's one of the reasons why
this kind of labeling by the russians as
polls as being stupid
uh is kind of prevalent but also if you
look at it
polish people actually have a very high
iq especially compared to that region
but but specifically it didn't work but
but another thing i want to bring up
because i saw a tweet i don't know
exactly who said this but it was by a
left-wing verified user talking about
how
he wants to make sure that trump
supporters can't ever be teachers
uh professors uh and any kind of
workers that have any kind of work that
has kind of um
powers to be a boss or to influence yes
i don't know the exact tweet so i don't
want to mention it
you know directly but but we're seeing
kind of similar epithets
being issued by blue checkmark verified
twitter users that are worrying
and that do echo some other historical
uh
timelines that are troublesome and john
brennan saying that no no one who served
in the trump administration should ever
get a job anywhere else it reminds me of
uh uh debarthification in iraq
anyone who's part of the bath party you
can't let them do anything from society
it's the same people doing it that's
literally what we were talking about
yesterday that brought onto the onset of
isis that was one of the key moves
according to many strategists that
brought
isis to the national stage was that
particular move that you brought up
sorry go ahead tim
i was gonna say i think the the the
thing we're saying about poland is
really interesting because
yeah they want to get rid of the
intelligent the intelligentsia the
thought leaders the cultural leaders
in poland and we're seeing a similar
thing with mass censorship
they want to take out the influential
people of you know right-wing populism
and at the same time what you see with
poland is a deep
hatred for communism and fascism or
nazism
because they were oppressed by both so
now you have this country that's like
we're going to defend the right of our
citizens because we know exactly what it
leads to
regardless of your la if your left wing
or right wing
i remember seeing a meme recently and it
said dangerous tools
of uh insurrection and it had a guitar
and it had a paint paintbrush
and and we have to understand here the
bigger cultural aspects and institutions
are pretty much
more and more political for a reason and
they're extorting a lot of that power a
lot of that kind of culture a lot of
that kind of
influence in ways that really should
make people question what's really going
on here
but you can tell how the tech companies
really messed up because it's not just
poland and hungary who have been opposed
to inaccessible for a while and poland
was working on this
before the trump bans so was hungary but
it's also alarmed
germany and france and the uk and
australia
because you know all of those countries
you know they run by fairly you know
neo-liberal or left-wing governments
especially germany and they have hate
speech laws on the books
but they look at what silicon valley is
doing and and are thinking well hold on
it's our job to define what hate speech
is that's a job of our national
parliaments our governments
we're not going to have silicon valley
coming and set the rules for us yeah
many people don't understand
in large parts of europe if you utter
some words together you literally will
end up in jail there's people who just
said particular sounds
they are in jail we in the united states
have an amazing
uh right that's inherent for i think
everyone
to be able to exercise our free speech
but again
that is directly under threat right now
with all the major avenues of
communication
squashing down and making sure people
can't have a voice online well this is
an interesting question because is it
are the government consequences worse
now than the corporate consequences in
america
so at least in the in europe you know
when the state defines hate speech
that's governed by some form of
parliamentary procedure there's a
democratic process it's transparent they
can't just change it overnight
and they can't apply it arbitrarily has
to apply to everyone according to the
law where
there's accountability in a court
proceeding that happens sorry go ahead
indeed
and uh silicon valley they can change it
overnight they can apply to just to one
set of people and not to another
uh and uh the consequences can
potentially be more severe you could
lose your entire livelihood your entire
business
whereas in europe mostly you might get a
fine uh it was count down for the right
to go like an 800 pound fine
is that worse than being demonetized and
by youtube i think anything demonetizes
following the arrest and the smears he
did get that as well you know it was it
was an arrest it was a charge it was
you know criminal trial and then silicon
valley piles on it exactly exactly
i'll tell you what's scarier than
twitter banning someone
what's scary is banks banning people or
vendors banning people
what we're seeing now is is one of the
most dis uh look
i'll say the word dystopian nightmarish
all that stuff
but let me just stress this point we're
at we are in this
space now where almost every corporation
is terrified of everyone walking in
lockstep
and banning any wrong thinker it doesn't
matter if there's a government doing it
it doesn't there's no this is this is
scarier there's no head to this hydra
or the snake it is literally a chicken
with no head running around freaking out
and so you'll get so uh there was there
was a tweet where some guy uh was
applying for a company
they found out that he was a trump
supporter and he had actively supported
trump
you know quite heavily so they were just
like they fired him that's where we're
headed
we're headed to where the company will
say something like look man i honestly i
voted for the guy but
you know the activists so we we can't
hire you
and then you see what happens to parlor
what you see you see what the ceo of
parlor just said he doesn't think
parlo's coming back
may never return wow yep because no one
will work with them
and the left says see the free market
i'm like it's a really good point about
the problems of a free market
in that there could be an ideology
behind whether or not anyone would do
business with you
i mean i would argue i guess
philosophically a free market is free
from
over overarching ideologies that would
you know impede or shut down
but where we're at now it is worse it is
the mexican standoff of cancel culture
every single person now whether they
like it or not
are scared about what will happen there
are companies that i know
that are i should say i have i have
friends who are associated with certain
companies
they like trump or they love trump or
they're neutral and don't care but they
all recognize if anyone finds out
we'll lose everything why because
everyone is scared of everyone else
no one knows who's gonna be the person
to raise the pitchfork why are you
scared of these people
the only way that stops if people say i
don't care you can yell on the internet
so what i mean jon stewart mill talked
about the tyranny of the majority where
uh everyone sort of behaves in a way and
you know clamps down
but this is less tearing off the
majority because if you ask the majority
of people
do you think you know people who support
trump should be able to have jobs i mean
i think most people would agree with
that this is the kind it's tyranny of
herd behavior
right of a very specific group of people
who are in power and all believe
this but it's a very small group of
people who just happen to be running all
the corporations
it is it is people scared of being
called a racist and so they're like but
if i serve this person then they'll call
me a racist
so what god just grow up man i can't
believe
that there are businesses that were like
we can't do we can't work with you
parlor we're scared
yeah that's pathetic and you know what
this is on conservatives too you have to
vote with your dollars
do not support anybody who would bow and
bend to this
herd you know what did you call it heard
tyranny
yeah tyranny of the hurdle heard
behavior right
we can't we we can't do this if
someone's gonna bend the knee to a bunch
of screaming people
then we're not gonna be able to function
all right so you need to be able to run
your business
and stand up for what you believe in and
yet the problem is i think
republicans the political party is a
spineless
massive there's i'm sorry spineless is
not fair it's a bowl of spaghetti it's a
bunch of wet noodles flopping around in
congress
who for years knew this problem existed
and you know and i said in 2018 i said
republicans are too stupid
to know you know to solve they're too
stupid to address the problem of big
tech censorship
and that's the politicians there are
some people who have consistently
brought
republicans who have brought forth bills
challenging this calling out big tech
my respect to them but most of them have
just been flopping around like wet
noodles
doing whatever they're told then you end
up with someone like jared kushner
brad parscale tells donald trump get on
parlor
get on a different platform and then
trump says what do you think to jared
and kushner goes nah don't do it and
trump goes okay
and now here you are now hold on trump's
lucky
because while he may not have had the
understanding or experience
to actually solve this and was getting
bad advice from people like kushner
other people saw it coming and lo and
behold
gab.com has archived and backed up the
real donald trump account
verified 1.2 million followers and all
of his tweets up to the point
i think there's some tweets that are
missing but for the most part his entire
account
is here with videos and statements and
at any point trump could just
use it now my question is right now why
isn't trump using it
why doesn't he still just go on use gab
there it is well he'd overload the site
for sure because they're using
their own infrastructure but at a
certain point trump should just
okay i'll use whatever platform i can
he's one of those stupid republicans man
i think trump's old and he's and and i
don't even know if he
there actually i'll tell you this there
was a donald trump schedule post went
out i don't know if it was real
but it said something like trump is
going to be working very very hard he'll
be working all day
working very hard having many meetings
yeah phone calls and people are like did
trump write this
like it sounds just like he wrote it
yeah did you saw that
i did so maybe it's just that he doesn't
have any advice anymore
and he's just not talking to anybody and
he's sitting around like i don't know
was it written in sharpie because it was
that was him and we'll have many many
meetings and phone calls
but this is this is great what gab did
because even if you don't like the
president or if you like the president
this is an important historical record
where major
events unfolded on that twitter account
that are
historically relevant so i mean the
bigger question that you
you kind of mention here what's stopping
him i don't think anything should be i
think he should be using any kind of
platform that promotes
free speech he just did this this
statement saying like no violence and
and all that but he also said i want to
call out
the the big tech censorship well bro
just go ahead and get on gab
yeah go on yeah get on gab there you go
i mean
there needs to be industry-wide reform
to a number of industries including
banking including
credit cards including big tech because
you can't have a situation where you've
got a two-tiered society where some
people have access to the economy and
some people don't
but i will say gab.com is the one
example of build your own actually
working
because they had many many challenges
they lost their web host they lost their
dns registrar
but they overcame all that they built
their own servers they're building their
own phones and
they're building their own phones
they've built their own web browser
servers
i mean they're having trouble handling
the traffic right now they've got a huge
search they're built
bringing more servers online but you
know they're still up and running they
haven't taken them out
although i will say just today we're
seeing that now the desperation
of uh the people who don't want internet
freedom the anti-defamation league
has petitioned the uh the justice
department to launch a criminal
investigation into gab
for hosting violent content well there
you go see now they're trying to
get into the criminal realm but we got a
constitution we'll see how that plays
out thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you